how's it going everybody it's Warren and
welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays sorry I didn't have one last
week every time I would open up an email
it would be the leaked footage from
Avengers and game or somebody telling me
about the leaked footage from Avengers
in game so in order to avoid spoilers I
simply didn't do it last week I
apologize I hope you understand but we
have some great theories to go over this
week and I'll be posting a video soon so
you can vote on who you think should win
for the month of April alright so you
all know how it works each week you all
submit your theories I choose 5 to go
over you all vote on which one you
thought was the best for the week and
then you vote on which one you thought
was the best for the month if you would
like to submit a theory of your own for
a chance to end up on Theory Thursdays
you can find the email to send it to in
the description down below alright let's
get started with some theories but just
the heads up most of these theories are
about what happens in Avengers in game
and what is about to take place after
avengers endgame so if you haven't seen
the movie you may want to skip this
week's episode theory number one comes
from Jordan gondola and he says that
it's very likely that Dormammu can
return in Avengers in game Fanus
destroyed all of the Infinity stones and
of course he destroyed the time stone
and the time stone was really the only
thing keeping Dormammu from coming back
to earth without the time stone now in
the current universe their mom who can
come back and once he finds out that the
time stone is destroyed he most likely
will this does make a lot of sense
considering the fact that Dormammu only
left in dr. strange because Doctor
Strange trapped him in a time loop yes
Doctor Strange was there but it was the
time stone that helped him win the fight
against Dormammu and not even really win
because Doctor Strange was trapped in
time as well but without the time stone
he can no longer do that so derp Mamu
could realize this and take a trip back
to earth
so that's theory number 1 on to theory
number 2
theory number 2 comes from Kathryn Henry
and Catherine's theory is about Tony
Stark wielding all of the Infinity
stones Catherine asked how was Tony
Stark able to hold the Infinity stones
long enough to perform the snap he
should have died
why didn't he well Catherine says back
in Iron Man number 2 when Tony was sick
with his arc reactor poisoning Nick Fury
had Natasha shoot him with a drug he
told him that it was lithium dioxide but
what if it was
a small dosage of gh-325 Cree blood
Tony immediately healed up from his
symptoms years later and it being a
small dose of course he wouldn't have
that running through his veins but what
if it attached itself to his DNA not
much but it's there the Cree race were
very powerful and for a limited time can
wield a stone in their bare hands what
if Tony's DNA having a little bit of
crib LUT in it is why he was able to
wield the Infinity stones long enough to
snap his fingers this is an interesting
theory because based on what we know
about the Infinity stones Tony should
not have been able to hold them for that
long and the snap probably should have
just simply disintegrated him I mean
professor Hulk was barely able to wield
the Infinity stones and he is a lot
stronger than Tony Stark so maybe there
is some underlying cause such as his
blood is actually infused with Kree
blood that helped him be strong enough
to hold the power of the Infinity stones
long enough to perform the snap after
all in Captain Marvel we did see carol
danvers get infused with Kree blood so
it's certainly something that Marvel has
thought about before so this could be
possible and maybe that's how Tony Stark
was able to wield the Infinity stones
for as long as he did so that's theory
number two on to number three
theory number three comes from Jakob
Sanchez and he has a theory about secret
wars originally Jakob thought that the
snap would create two different
universes however after watching
Avengers endgame we know that is not the
case however we know that the Avengers
going back in time and messing up a
little bit such as Loki escaping with
the space stone and 2014 Gamora being in
2023 now and 2014 nebula dying we know
that they have created alternate
timelines which is essentially multiple
alternate universes so Jakob says that
all these different universes and
timelines being created catches the
attention of the Beyonder and he
observes from a distance even after the
Avengers defeat Thanos and Captain
America returns all the Infinity stones
back in time they have still created
these alternate timelines so the
Beyonder decides to fuse these timelines
and universes together creating an event
like Secret Wars
which would be a great way to introduce
the x-man and the Fantastic Four into
their universe as well and eventually
battle world could be introduced and
crossovers and introductions would
create a whole different new adventure
for the MCU this is certainly a very
interesting
theory because we know Disney now owns
all the rights to the x-men and the
Fantastic Four and the MCU is going to
continue after the events of Avengers
endgame in fact spider-man far from home
will acknowledge what happened in
Avengers in game so in the universe
everybody knows that the snap happened
but the alternate timeline is that the
Avengers created could introduce mutants
somehow and we actually already know
that the cosmic entities exist in the
MCU in fact the writers of infinity war
and Avengers endgame have just recently
come out and said that they were going
to have the Living Tribunal in Avengers
infinity war so we know that they're
going this route so bringing the
Beyonder in to fuse the universes and
timelines together isn't exactly too
far-fetched in fact it seems like
they're leaning more towards that but
cosmic entities entering the MCU so this
could be a great way to lead into things
such as battleworld and to introduce the
x-men and the Fantastic Four
so that was theory number three on to
number four theory number four comes
from Alex P and Alex has a theory about
how the x-men and the Fantastic Four
will enter the MCU and join the avengers
eventually Alex says that now that Tony
Stark is gone and that Captain America
is an old man Nick Fury is going to have
to recruit new members for the Avengers
he reunites with Captain Marvel at the
end and Captain Marvel goes into the
cosmos to search for people before she
leaves Nick Fury tells her I've had some
people under my radar for a long time
and I think it may be time to call them
and these people will end up being the
Fantastic Four and at one point in time
could even have worked for shield
meanwhile Carol Danvers goes somewhere
in the universe and find some people who
are super should recruit them to come
back to earth and these people will be
the x-men one thing I like about this
theory is that Nick Fury knows about the
Fantastic Four all along which probably
makes sense because he's the master
super spy and he basically ran shield so
he has to know about all of these
different people on earth and the origin
story of the Fantastic Four has already
been done on the big screen so maybe you
do it like spider-man and Captain Marvel
where you don't have a typical origin
story but you start off right when they
already have their powers and maybe they
did work for shield the scientists and
something went wrong with an experiment
and that's how they got their powers and
we already know that Captain Marvel has
explored the universe and other galaxies
as well so she's most likely ran into
some other super people before the
thing is that there are so many
different possibilities for Marvel to
bring in the x-men and the Fantastic
Four
so that's theory number four on to the
final theory number five theory number
five comes from Alfred Norwin barbacena
and he has a theory about the name war
easter-egg and Avengers in game an
Avengers endgame Ikoyi mentions an
underground earthquake off the coast of
Africa many people believe that this is
an Easter Egg to name war and that name
war is going to be the villain in Black
Panther - Alfred believes this and
believes there will be a war between
Wakanda and Atlantis but Alfred thinks
that they have something in common that
they're both super technologically
advanced more than any other
civilizations in the world
Alfre thinks that some vibranium maybe
came from outer space and landed in the
ocean which is where Atlanteans get all
of their technology from just like
wakandans so in black panther 2 we'll
see the Battle of the two nations the
two most technologically advanced
civilizations on the planet and we will
see Namor versus Black Panther I like
this theory because I too believe that
the underground earthquake was
referencing Namor in Avengers in game
he's been teased coming into the MCU for
a very long time now by Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige and it makes sense
if a meteor came from space landing in
Wakanda giving them their vibranium then
maybe another meteor landed in the ocean
giving Atlanteans vibranium this would
definitely make for an interesting
battle a battle between the two most
advanced cities on the planet this is
something that actually happens in the
comics Wakanda and Atlantis are at
constant war with one another so this
theory could definitely happen well
that's it for this week's theories let's
do a quick recap theory number one is
that Dormammu will return this is due to
Thanos destroying the time stone
Dormammu finds out and returns to earth
theory number two is that Tony was
actually able to wield the power of all
the Infinity stones because Nick Fury
and Natasha actually put Kree blood into
him in Iron Man 2 Theory number 3 is
that the Avengers going back in time and
creating alternate timelines catches the
attention of the Beyonder he then fuses
all of the timelines together and we get
a version of Secret Wars theory number
four is that Nick Fury and Captain
Marvel are going to be the ones to bring
in the x-men Nick Fury will bring in the
Fantastic Four and Captain Marvel will
bring in some x-men from other planets
and theory number five is about the
Namor easter-egg and that in black
panther 2 we will see black panther go
against Namor and antlion
so those are all this week's theories
for Theory Thursday be sure to vote on
which one you think is your favorite and
just a reminder now that Avengers
endgame has come out you can submit
theories about anything it could be
Avengers related spider-man related
x-men Fantastic Four related it could be
Batman it could be detective Pikachu
anything you want and again if you would
like to submit your own theory for a
chance to end up on Theory Thursdays you
can find the email to send them to and
the instructions in the description down
below again don't forget to vote on
which theory is your favorite and if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on all
Theory Thursdays and so you can stay up
to date on everything Marvel and all
things superhero as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]
you